ha caído la noche en Ucrania y a esta
hora continúan la búsqueda de
sobrevivientes en ese edificio
Residencial de la ciudad de denipro que
fue atacada ayer durante ese ataque con
misiles masivos llevado a cabo por el
gobierno de Moscú que a propósito hoy
dijo que había alcanzado todos los
objetivos con ese ataque aunque no se
refirió exactamente a este edificio las
imágenes que han quedado con este ataque
tienen conmovido a los ucranianos que en
las últimas semanas y meses habían visto
como estos misiles Y estos drones
kamikasis alcanzaban especialmente la
infraestructura eléctrica y otra
infraestructura importante en el país
pero no eran ataques tan masivos a
lugares con habitados por civiles como
el que sucedió ayer que hace recordar
otro ataque muy grande que sucedió en la
ciudad de kramatoros que en el donbas
donde nos encontramos esta noche cuando
en abril otro ataque dijo al menos 60
personas fallecidas y casi un centenar
de heridos de decenas y decenas de
personas que en ese momento estaban allí
esperando ser evacuadas de la ciudad
pero entonces los rusos negaron haber
hecho este ataque algo que no hicieron
hoy